if you could get the financing today  for any project that you have written  something you've always wanted to make  uh what would you make and why  well i mean developing this thing for  hbo which is  which is a um a limited series about a  about a a virus that causes stupidity  and it's based on a screenplay i wrote  which is based on a novel  called iq 83 and um i'm actually  developing it for them so it's possible  that it's going to happen i don't know  that it's going to happen  but i'm very interested in because of  the circumstances in which we live i'm  very interested in  exploring the notion of that and um  and treating it as a you know kind of a  metaphor